you can see this can't you in cities
like Philly where over the weekend 100
Kids ransacked a Wawa convenience store
even jumping on cars and the parking lot
it's this searing contempt for your city
and your fellow citizens that produces
this heinous level of violence
and last week a mother and her teenage
daughter in Philadelphia were ambushed
outside their home just after six in the
morning
the suspect threatened them with a gun
then drove off in the family car
police say that he was lying and wait
for them
and then on Saturday night a
two-year-old was shot in the back twice
that boy is in critical condition
yesterday a 19 year old died after being
shot get this 21 times
and just a few hours ago five members of
the high school football team were shot
after a scrimmage
now a 14 year old is dead
so how much longer will residents from
the City of Brotherly Love put up with
this
joining us now is David oh republican
Philadelphia city councilman David it's
good to see you tonight
our Philadelphia residents just numb to
this or are they finally going to demand
change
they are demanding change but I don't
think uh this has ended I think it will
continue to get worse because the
leadership of our city is not
recognizing that the the policies that
they've installed uh have produced this
type of wanton of violence in every
which direction we can see what you said
is true and we hear about it all the
time innocent children seniors uh people
just going about their own business
being shot multiple times and people who
really have nothing to do with any
criminal situation sometimes they're
just in a social media photograph with
someone
that other people are looking for they
can't find that person so they take it
out on someone who's simply in a
photograph and all of this has resulted
from just a lack of law enforcement a
disrespect aspect of the law and a
failure to hold people accountable and
so this is what is leading to this type
of crime and violence in our city
well there's no consequences there's
both no consequences and when you rip
down a bunch of statues and you Rampage
through the city claiming that you know
everything that ever came before was
awful rotten and racist guess what
nothing happened to you you were
celebrated
that's where we are and take families
out of the equation and then you're
really screwed
right we can we can look at six years
ago where the murders in this city was
about 280 or exactly 280 and last year
it was
561. as of right now we're at 401
murders and it continues
and and you know the the thing is that
uh we need to reverse a lot of these
policies that were put in place in our
city
um in our universities in our public
transportation system and in our schools
very permissive very lenient
um on people committing violent crimes
our prosecutor does not believe that
Prosecuting people with illegal weapons
um will reduce the crime rate yeah uh
that's where it is a yeah there's just
many examples of the failure yeah
councilman we know what to do people
accountable you are you are doing
yeoman's work we know what needs to be
done there needs to be consequences for
criminals they got to be locked up and
there's got to be a total change in
leadership otherwise what you see
happening tonight in Philadelphia last
week the week before the month before is
going to keep happening a lot of people
are going to be dead as a result
councilman thank you for joining us hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else